-Our next guest is a
talented actress and comedian
you know from shows like
"Search Party"
and "What We Do in the Shadows,"
and movies such as "Dating in
New York" and "The Lovebirds."
Her new special,
"The Twist? She's Gorgeous,"
begins streaming on Netflix
March 15.
Let's take a look.
-I hate the summer.
All I've ever done in a bikini
is sob.
[ Audience laughs ]
But one thing I love about
summer,
[chuckles] I have to say,
is those hot,
hot summer anthems.
So if the DJ could just drop
that track real quick,
that'd be sick.
[ Upbeat piano music plays ]
I'm really more of a dancer
than a comedian.
Dancer first, choreographer
second, model third,
comedian fourth.
-Please welcome back to
the show, our friend,
Catherine Cohen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Oh, my God, I'm so happy
to be back, finally.
-It's been -- it's weirdly
not as long --
or it's longer than I feel like
it's been since you were here.
-Well, I told my parents I was
coming on the show and my dad
was like, "Wow, I can't believe
we get to go to Seth Meyers
twice in one year."
And I said, "That was
three years ago, babe."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, it's been
a weird three years.
-I know.
-In his defense,
it's been a weird three years.
-I've loved it. No, it's been
absolute hell on Earth.
-Well, you know, it's
interesting because
you did a song, "Look at Me,"
which is the opening song
in the special.
-Yes.
-And I should -- you have
a beautiful singing voice.
This is incredible musical
comedy.
-Stop, stop.
-[ Laughs ]
-Seth, you're embarrassing me.
-But you -- this is the opening
song in your special.
So obviously, you've had a lot
of this material
for a long time because this is
a special that was supposed
to tape when the pandemic
happened, so it must be
so thrilling to have it
coming out.
-Truly, it's a dream come true.
-Yeah.
-I'm so psyched.
-And this is such a unique
to New York style of show,
this cabaret comedy show.
-Yes!
-What have -- [ Laughs ]
Yeah.
I'm about -- I'm really plugged
in to New York, so I know --
-[Laughing] I know, right?
-And what was it like when
Netflix called and said,
"We want to do this kind of show
for a standup special?"
-Well, [laughs] When they --
I've been working on the show
for many years.
I do a weekly show
at Club Cumming
in the East village.
I did the Edinburgh Fringe,
which I know, you know and love.
-Yes, the best.
-The best, the best.
And then I hurt my vocal cords
and I couldn't talk for,
like, two months.
So when Netflix called to tell
me I was going to get a special,
they told me the news and I
literally couldn't say a word.
I was on vocal rest.
I was like...
[ Laughs ]
-Feverishly clapping the phone.
On the other line they're like,
"OK, well, bye.
Like, reach out."
But then I was, you know,
physically very excited.
-You've been doing this a long
time -- as you mentioned,
working on this show a long
time, and this is very unique
for us. You and Patty,
our previous guest,
worked together over the years.
-Stop!
-This is a sketch you did?
-Yeah, it's highbrow art,
performance art.
-OK, and what is the name --
what would you call
this sketch?
-This was called Slurp.
It was about two girlies
just rubbing ice cream
all over their faces.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's kind of probably over
your head, so I don't --
-Yeah, no.
I think without the context,
we're all like, "Wow."
But I think most of us
want to see it.
-Absolutely.
It's out there in the cloud.
Yeah.
-So you grew up in Texas.
You attended Christian schools.
Are people thrown by the path
you've chosen to take?
-I know, because I became
an absolute wretched slut, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I --
-Which is, like, the one thing.
It was, like, they had that in
Latin.
Don't do that.
-That's what they always said.
No, my dad's Jewish,
my mom's Catholic.
I went to these Christian
schools, and then I just got,
like, too horny and I left.
-Yeah.
-I left it all behind.
-Was that, like, sort of
a mutual split?
Did they sort of
also appreciate it?
They're like,
"New York might better."
-I think, yeah, this
is a much better fit.
Yeah, but there you go.
-Part of what makes your
stage show so compelling
is it's incredibly honest.
Are there, though, things
that you do on stage,
maybe things in the special,
that you were on the fence about
whether or not you wanted
to include?
-Oh, so many things.
-[ Laughs ]
-We'll find out tomorrow
what the verdict is.
You know, I have a story about
-- how do I put this?
I'm a very romantic woman.
I need to send a picture of
my crotch to, you know, lovers,
doctors, that kind of thing.
-Right, right.
[ Laughter ]
-And so I was taking a photo
of my crotch
and I didn't realize
that I was on selfie mode.
And so in the background,
I saw my face just complete --
[ Laughter ]
Dead-eyed. You know when you
accidentally take a selfie,
and it's just like --
-Right.
-It's a harrowing moment.
-Well, it's harrowing because
you realize
that's how most people see
your face all the time.
-Nonstop.
I mean, yeah, look at it, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Totally.
So that made the cut, so yeah.
More where that came from.
More gold.
-You're doing Netflix is a Joke,
it's a festival.
-Yes.
-This spring.
That's so exciting.
-I'm so excited.
-You're also doing shows
in Los Angeles.
I would say, "tell people
where to get tickets,"
but I've also heard
it's sold out.
-Stop. I love that.
That's great news.
-Well, I heard it
via your people.
-I told you that, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I don't know
if that's true."
I'm like, "Well, Seth,
it's sold out."
No, I'm psyched.
-It must be so great.
And I would only imagine
it's going to be so exciting
to do material
after people see this special.
-Yes.
-Is there then this pressure
to have new stuff?
-Absolutely.
I'm working on a new hour.
The old jokes feel very old.
I feel like having, you know,
two years of waiting to tape it,
I ended up having to listen to
an old recording of myself
to remember my jokes, and I was
like, "Who's that girl?
She sounds fabulous."
I was like, "My brain is broken.
I don't know what any of that
is anymore."
But we got back there.
-Well, I'm very happy
that it's available
for everybody to see.
-Oh, I'm so happy.
-And it is so nice to have you
back on the show.
Thank you for making time
for us.
-Thank you so much.
It's truly a dream come true.
-You guys,
that's Catherine Cohen!
"The Twist? She's Gorgeous"
is streaming tomorrow
on Netflix, and
Netflix is a Joke, the festival,
begins April 28th
in Los Angeles.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."